[Music]
LS is one of the most beloved names and
league of legends and sometimes one of
the most controversial you know walk up
he's gonna think wait I'm not six I want
to drop an f-bomb I play with me like
the [ __ ] Western [ __ ]
but getting to that point was a grueling
challenge the pressure that she always
came when I felt like I wasn't good
enough for someone or something or you
know whatever else there's a front page
reddit post flaming me personally as a
human being every other [ __ ] week you
think I wouldn't take it to heart I
couldn't find ways to financially
stabilize I couldn't find ways to
emotionally stabilize so I don't know it
was scary at times if you watch any
League of Legends you probably already
know who LS is from coaching to
streaming to casting he does it all and
over the years he's become a huge name
in the League of Legends community
welcome back to DLC guys I'm des LS but
Alice wasn't always a league fan before
he was the number one nè advocate and
liandry's salesman LS was trying to make
it pro in StarCraft but in 2007 LS made
a terrible catastrophic mistake he
cheated star cross is kind of like my
escape in my life
so I just wanted to be known so I didn't
think I was hurting anyone I wanted to
you know beat these players to kind of
befriend them if that makes sense and
then play normal against them and
actually become better like them and
then play them naturally and never hurt
anyone
LS was banned through the team liquid
forum the hub of the Western Starcraft
community his career was basically over
and the scene tom is a criminal even
nowadays you know I had set this on
streams on several occasions I see kids
but at 12 13 14 15 and I could never
imagine saying to them things that board
members on Team Liquid dotnet said to me
I could never imagine going out of my
way to harass them or basically make
threads dedicated to like claiming them
write equivalent to like cyberbullying
now let's continue to play Starcraft but
the community still hated him some
people even banned him from tournament
eventually he moved to his dad's house
where he didn't have a pc good enough to
play the game so he just quit but then
Blizzard released brood wars successor
it's about time Starcraft 2 came out in
2010 but LS didn't really care he was
too busy trying to find a place to live
but during this period of uncertainty LS
got an opportunity to return to
Starcraft and even make some money doing
it and so I got a message on facebook
from the ghost gamers admin mark Kuhn
who apparently was managing or he's
gonna be managing a course to gamers on
that team so he gave me an offer that
you would put me on salary and get me a
computer to come out of retirement I
would play at Starbucks and I would play
at Dunkin Donuts on the Wi-Fi and
eventually it became a problem and it
got to a point where I would wait at the
end of the street of my mother's house I
would wait to wait for her to go to work
and then I would break in through the
basement although he was now a
retirement LS still didn't really have a
place to live
he was couchsurfing but that was far
from a permanent
solution what happened was one day I got
caught at my mother's and that
eventually it was a very very big
blowout and I was on a Skype call with
six jacks cue name's Alex berola and he
heard the whole thing and sku just said
you need to get out of there and I'll
just get you a plane ticket and I flew
out to Arizona and what happened is
after MLG Anaheim we got back and him
and his brother had a really big fight
in the kitchen about me staying there
because skew had told them that I was
staying shorter than what apparently was
happening and less just couldn't stay on
his friends couch in Arizona anymore he
was out of options so he packed up
everything and at just 18 years old he
moved to Korea and so I asked the the
owner of ghosts of gamers at the time I
asked him to use up all of my stipend
and like future salary stuff to send me
one way to Korea and I landed there with
less than $2 ls had a relatively cheap
place to stay at the MVP gaming house
after passing a few tests but that's it
that's all he had and when I arrived in
Korea it was like a nightmare for about
a year or two years because I had less
than $200 basically in my pocket at all
times
I was extremely reliant on like taste
ptosis and stuff or like just
connections my income was extremely
unstable coaching wasn't really big back
then like you could only get like 20 $30
an hour and it was very infrequent the
community still hated me because they
all thought like I was like this grown
adult at this time that had cheated when
I was like 20 even though they don't
take into account I was like 12 13 so
there was a lot of problems there on top
of the money problem Ellis was also
dealing with depression he was alone in
a foreign country and didn't speak the
language he was broke and he couldn't
talk to anyone about it between the
depression and the homelessness and
being broke
Ellis had to put his Starcraft dreams on
hold he was still playing but all those
situations were weighing him down he
couldn't give it his all I felt very
isolated and alone and I was also
struggling and dealing with like a lot
of internal conflict I was dealing with
coming to terms with like my sexuality
and I was dealing with
you know really being on my own at that
point
LS moved to another team house but
eventually he was homeless and broke
with almost nothing to his name he
gathered up whatever he had a left and
risked it all on poker and I was going
to the casino of thinking this is all
the money that I have and it was only a
couple hundred and I legitimately
thought like if I lose this I have
nothing the gamble paid off
LS made enough to afford a very small
room in South Korea and the windfall put
a more permanent roof over his head but
you don't always win in poker and when
you have almost nothing the losses sting
some days LS eight as little as possible
to stretch out his winnings it wasn't
healthy
the MVP coach I went to meet with him
because I bought the computer off him
all right I bought a new computer off
him and he saw me and he's like what
happened because I must have I I lost so
much weight and I must have looked like
a [ __ ] skeleton so he had a talk with
the house and the other coach that was
living there because they were going to
swap it into a legal evans house and he
talked with the people that were
currently there because there was an
issue with if I could come back or not
because I was gay and the coach knew at
that point you know well the coach knew
before I left MVP to go live in the Gong
house so there was that whole debacle so
he said that he had to talk and you had
to think about it and make a decision
and they made a decision and they said I
could come back and that was the start
of everything for the first time in a
while LS could devote his all to
competing and soon he got a shot at
redemption
Starcraft legend day 9 gave him an
opportunity that he desperately needed
who the hell is last shadow last shadow
I would describe as one of two players I
really genuinely feared playing against
thanks to the boost in popularity from
day9 streams LS was invited to writable
battlegrounds Austin a tournament that
featured big names like Ballmer and
Stephano
if LS one in Austin or even just placed
well he would prove to the Starcraft
community that he wasn't just a cheater
that he was a good player worth taking
seriously unfortunately for LS his big
break turned out to be a nightmare
before I even started playing I got
basically pranked on skype by my friend
Hongbin at the time who basically told
me that after I left I couldn't go back
to the pro gaming house and that I would
have to find somewhere new to stay so I
was freaking the [ __ ] out and there was
also stuff going on with my family at
the time and in my personal life that I
was being made aware of over Facebook it
just felt like what the [ __ ] am I doing
here why am I here
I remember going and playing my Series
and I didn't want to play them LS left
Austin without a win and got even more
flak from the Starcraft community all of
a sudden he was a cheater and a loser
all that took its toll on him so l s
decided to take a break from Starcraft
and he turned to a new game one that
would finally offer him for damn sure
[Music]
l s made the jump from Starcraft to
league by playing and learning the game
with future world champions like it but
then he hit another roadblock by lung
disease but I had at the time Korea
wasn't able to diagnose it it had been
going on since the end of November I
kept having to travel up to Seoul for
blood work and you know x-rays and cat
scans and everything eventually
everything just wasn't making sense and
I had to go and get tested for HIV
because you know stereotype and I just
heard it's not HIV it's tuberculosis and
I just let out like a sigh of relief
because I'm like aw [ __ ] at least this
can be cure obviously tuberculosis is
still really scary but it wasn't tumor
Colossus a doctor from New York made the
diagnosis that it was a BPA allergic
bronchopulmonary aspergillosis and as
soon as they started me on the
medication I just did a complete
turnaround in terms of health once he
recovered and reached a high enough rank
in Korean soloqueue now let's begin
offering a service that would come to
define the next few years of his life
coaching so you're standing here now
mundo is Auto attacking these level
so he has the cleaver right and the
cleaver Swift is literally like the size
of the line so because of all of this
right you're in Italy you shouldn't be
standing here you should be standing in
between these minions right and if mundo
comes down you swing up and you Otto
Otto Otto Otto
it started with his viewers but soon the
prose started taking notice so some
things that I want to address is that so
I joined shc about a month and a half
ago teams started approaching LS and
under his leadership supa hot crew went
from relegation in the u LCS to playoffs
because the residents he's doing work
they will take down the two Nexus
turrets and the super Hawk crew will
finish third in the standings that means
they will be facing rocket and the walls
and after that success my last one to
coach even more teams after helping a
couple different teams he's made his way
to gravity and the North American LCS
he's outside of Korea finally less
shadow you guys you won your first match
was that all you so for those that did
follow what was going on I ended up
coaching a team again for the first time
in an official setting and I joined
tempo storm in May with LS sitting in
the middle obviously going to be one of
the coaches for sure--they
drafting coach and the analytical coach
can't wait to see what kind of thing
people concoct and in 2016 he'll s made
is casting debut joining SPO TV for
their inaugural broadcast of the l ck
and that led him to be on the broadcast
desk for the 2016 League of Legends
World Championships and although he left
SPO TV in 2017 LS returned to the l ck
broadcast in 2019 becoming the league's
premier caster i don't even know what
they're thinking right now just Oh Jase
is disabled so is Kenan but even Kenan
is awful into this spot okay no idea
what to even say about it and remember
this is or the
a chef's knife paladin hunter road
warrior enchanter tape cruiser wizard
rowlock priests assassin gunslinger true
at shaman necromancer ninja bard monk
robot conjurer a blacksmith mystic
warding god illusionist templar wizard
showing what he can really do here over
these the last few years
LS hasn't just been coaching and casting
he's also become one of the biggest
streamers in league you guys wanna see
why I tell you all the pick Annie give
me give me one second I'm gonna show you
all why we pick Annie ready now if you
were syndra some of you may have missed
the cue and unlike me you can't blame it
on ping sure sometimes his opinions
really piss off the community cosplay
and I go on reddit we had so many
[ __ ] threads for literally saying the
[ __ ] truth about what's going on can
literally open up probe you can go
through all of doing B's games you can
literally pinpoint how poorly he's
actually playing the lane poor
autoattacks poor positioning or they see
that I can be very stern or no [ __ ]
with some of my takes and I can be very
abrasive and I think that that leads to
people not looking at like other stuff
that I do but he's built up a dedicated
passionate fan base who stick with him
whether he's Coast dreaming the LCS
chatting with pros or just messing
around in soloqueue it's a bit of an
advanced insult like for someone who his
room looks like mordekaiser's old I am
the undie lck color caster and I will be
casting lck tomorrow and I have no
[ __ ] idea what that champion does his
journey was filled with excruciating
adversity but he never gave up he proved
his critics wrong showing the world that
he was more than just some 13 year old
cheater
LS bet everything on himself and it all
paid off
going from literal poverty an actual
homelessness inside of Korea
five and a half years ago to where I'm
at now is [ __ ] I I don't even know
League is a league reddit twitch riot
words don't really capture what it's
done for me thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages